(bright upbeat music)
- Is the end goal here
that abortion be illegal,
and it be criminalized,
and removed as a resource
forever from this country?
Is that the...
- Illegal and unthinkable.
So it is criminalized and stigmatized?
(enchanting music)
- If you agree, step forward,
if you disagree, stay put.
Nobody likes abortions.
- I don't think anyone likes it.
I think they use it and they
might use it incorrectly
from my perspective.
But I don't think anyone
likes an abortion.
Like they're not like jumping for joy for.
- I think it is a very
physically taxing process
to go through.
And I don't think anyone
would want to intentionally
have an abortion.
I think those who get an
abortion most of the time,
it's because they need to.
- It's a harmful narrative on
both sides of the conversation
to say that, you know,
women celebrate abortion.
I think it creates a prejudice
around women who do get abortions.
And I don't think that it's good
to kind of the decision of abortion
from either side, from
the perspective, so.
- Can the disagree step forward?
- I think if you asked me this question,
maybe several years ago,
I would've said nobody likes abortion,
but I think in today's climate,
it is much more celebrated.
As a pro-life person,
I've had people tell me
that they will dedicate
their next abortion to me
instead of helping women,
they will have an abortion.
- I've heard very
similar responses to you.
Things like I'll donate to
planned parenthood in your name.
And there's other pages
like Shout Your Abortion
that openly celebrates abortion rights.
- Yeah, I celebrate abortion
and I think that campaigns
like Shout Your Abortion
aren't about like getting in your face,
but women who choose to have abortions
suffer a lot of stigma and trauma
from people who stand outside clinics
and have grotesque images
and literally, you know,
damning your soul abortion
as a medical procedure and resource
is something that I do celebrate.
It's a human right
and I love abortion.
My name is Rocky You SheHer,
pronounced I'm from Austin, Texas.
And I am very pro-abortion.
I think that legislation
like SB-Eight opens the door
and the path towards handing over
our bodily autonomy to the state.
I don't understand how anyone can justify
using their personal beliefs
to take away the rights of others.
- My name's Abby, I'm
from Orlando, Florida.
And I'm an abolitionist of human abortion.
We have to ask the question
of what makes humans valuable.
So because my world view as a Christian
gives me a foundation for human worth.
And because I believe scientifically
fetuses are human beings
on the moon of conception,
I am against abortion.
- Biological fathers should
have an equal say in abortions.
- Well, I think so.
I mean, it's consistency.
Like if we're defining that as a life,
if it is a life to put
a kid up for adoption,
both parents have to agree.
- I agree, I have talked to lots of women
who've had abortions
and I've talked to lots of men
who are hurting, their
they're completely heartbroken
they would've raised the baby.
They wanted to raise baby.
They begged for the life of the baby
and they obviously
created the baby together
but only one of them gets to decide
if their child gets to live or die.
- I would like to think
from more of a honestly
feminist perspective,
men have responsibility
as the other parent of that child.
Ironically enough, a lot of the times
when pro-choice people put
the focus on the woman,
they strict the man
of all his parental rights
and responsibilities.
And I think that's why actually
a lot of men who are
pro-choice, are pro-choice
because they don't wanna have
those fatherly responsibilities
that they will have
once the child is born.
- You've left us, man.
I wanna know why.
- (indistinct) struggle.
- I'm mad conflicted about this
because I strongly feel like a man
should not have control over what a woman
does with her body.
I more so have an issue
with when a man doesn't
actually want that baby.
She wants it and then expects
this man to like be the ultimate provider
and child care and all
this extra stuff, right?
But in the case of it, the man wanted it,
the baby and a woman didn't want it,
he has no say so.
I think that's (indistinct) up dynamic.
So that's why I was going back and forth.
- Well, you should have stayed then.
It sounds like you're for men
having more rights than that.
- I just can't force
women and be like, no,
you have to do this.
Cause I think it's (indistinct) up
it's her body.
- But it's also a child's life in there.
It's not just her body.
It's a child's life.
- And it's also your son or daughter.
- I think truly in my eyes,
it's like, it's my body.
I get to do what I want with it.
And I don't think anyone
including the person,
the other person who's involved
should have a say whether I wanna keep it
or whether I want to get an abortion.
- My name is Asher,
currently reside in Las Vegas
and I'm for pro-abortion.
I used to be against abortion
until an unwanted
pregnancy happened to me.
If you know for a fact
that you're not even
gonna be the best parent
for that child or you can't
provide for that child,
or maybe you're just fearful
and don't wanna pop a child outta you
or just whatever reason that you have.
I feel like you shouldn't
have to go through that.
You still have that choice
over your life, your body.
- I have had an abortion.
- A few months ago
I found out that I was pregnant.
So when I imagined myself
finding out I was pregnant
for the first time
I wanted it be celebrated.
And in that moment I
felt such severe anxiety
and having that, I felt,
like the entire time
I was just in a lot of
emotional pain, grieving.
I was debating about myself,
about how I would be looked at
or how I would view myself
after getting the procedure done.
- I ain't gonna lie, I'm nervous.
So I'm be real careful in my words.
Clearly as a man, I
can't have an abortion,
but my girlfriend,
we've had two abortions.
She didn't really want to have a baby.
I didn't really want to have a baby.
And I know for me,
I don't want to be that seen
as that deadbeat father person,
but I knew I wasn't really
trying to sacrifice my own dreams
or what I was trying to accomplish
to be a dad at that point.
- I think that's definitely
like one of the biggest things
to consider because I wasn't
in any kind of position
to be a mother, you know?
So it's like,
I wanna get my shit together
before I can have a baby
and give it a life that it deserves.
When I found out I was pregnant,
the person that I was with
at the time, they were like,
I will support you in every way,
but I will not be able to be there for you
if you decide to keep it.
And that definitely influenced my choice.
It was one of the hardest
decisions I've ever had to make.
I like to think I'm a pretty generous,
like loving person in the
names that I've been called
for even getting one.
I've gotten evil, psychotic, demented.
My name is Christine.
I'm from Denver and I am
on the anti-abortion side.
So when I was 20 years old,
I was a college student
and I found myself in
an unplanned pregnancy.
And I was pressured to abort very heavily,
not only by my child's father,
but by those around me.
And I heard my son's heartbeat
and there was no debate, it was a life.
His life was not mine to take.
This is part of why I am very pro-life
because I know many women
are pressured to abort
when they don't want to.
- Can the disagree a step forward?
- Your story is absolutely
powerful and your story as well.
I think something we
probably all can agree on
is abortion usually is a
symptom of a bigger problem,
whether it's finances, whether
it's stability of housing,
whether it's relationship issues,
my perspective is that
we address those issues
instead of ending the life of a child.
- I disagree, I don't think
that abortion is a symptom.
People should be able to access abortion
when, how, wherever they want or need.
I don't think that it's
a problem to be fixed.
I think that is still stigmatizing.
- But I think the biggest thing is that
there are birth control methods out there,
and abortion should not
be a birth control method.
I think that that's very critical.
And to hear that, you know,
you weren't celebrated,
I think life should be
celebrated with everybody.
- I'd like to call
attention to that point too.
Just the fact of using
abortion as birth control.
I thank you for everyone
sharing their stories so far.
I didn't step forward, I
haven't had an abortion myself.
But I am a survey ever of rape.
I was on birth control at the time
and I still made the
decision with my medical team
that birth control is not a
hundred percent effective.
And I wanted access to
emergency contraceptive
to take on top of that.
And had that pregnancy or
any of those methods failed,
I would've chosen to have an abortion
and I'm very grateful that I
had access to those resources
and I'm so mindful that
and many women who don't.
- Well, I think it gets down
to the heart of the issue here.
You know, what is the unborn?
Which scientifically the
embryo is from conception,
a living whole organism with distinct DNA.
As a Christian,
I come from a worldview that says that
every human being is,
has dignity and worth.
- Not to disrespect any
religion in general,
but in my eyes,
that's just pushing a belief onto someone
rather than actually stating
a real concrete fact.
- So, scientifically I'm
pro-life because of science,
not because of religion.
But scientifically, I believe that life
does start at conception.
I don't think it makes sense to put life
beginning at any other
place during pregnancy,
doing so usually ends up saying
that the already born
in person isn't alive,
such as consciousness,
heartbeat, et cetera.
There are many pro-life people here
here from the science perspective
who are not led by religious
motives at all, or partially.
I am Ayala, I am 18 years old.
I am from Charlotte, North Carolina.
And I am anti-abortion.
One misconception that I
deal with pretty frequently
is that we are all
Christian, white, old men.
And as a, you know, Jewish woman younger,
I really want more voices
like mine to be seen
in the anti-abortion movement
because I think we have new perspectives
that would help kind of bridge the gap
and have us find a little
bit of middle ground
between our two opposing sides.
- Abortion is murder.
- I think it is murder.
I think for the abortionist
more so than the woman,
I think a lot of women
don't necessarily know
exactly how an abortion
procedure is formed.
I've had a girl even
tell me that at 20 weeks
a baby is just a clump of
cells and that's just not true.
I do believe now there might
be cases where, you know,
some women might be unaware
of what's going on in an abortion.
But by and large,
I think especially with
the advent of the internet
and so much education out there,
many of them do know that the life,
that there's a life inside of them
and they want to end that life.
Whether they call it murder or not.
- Hard disagree, absolutely disagree.
- Okay.
- I've definitely met
a lot of teenage girls
who grew up in our generation
who believe that abortion is normal.
A fetus is Columbus cells
and there is no human life in the womb.
They don't tell you
when you go into an abortion consultation,
this is a child and this is a human life.
And then that's, what's
going to be happening.
I have a hard time believing
that if most women knew
they were killing a child,
they would do that.
I don't think women in
America are that malevolent.
I think it's very
irresponsible and very hurtful
to say, oh, this woman's a murderer
because she had an abortion.
- At least my personal experience,
the people who worked there
were very understanding.
They let me know there is a child
that could come out of you in nine months.
Are you sure you want to do this?
I knew there was a child in my body.
I knew I could have a
child in nine months.
And I knew that that child can
old and be their own person.
But I made that choice
because I'm allowed to have that choice.
And especially you, you are a white man.
And you are not allowed
to say what I can do
with my body,
nor any of these other women
who are able to carry a child.
- I think that's so dangerous.
I think that's so dangerous
to say that you can't say
because of your sexuality,
who you are as a male or female,
or how you believe as a religion,
you can't define what's right or wrong.
I think that's misguided
and we shouldn't take that in the policy.
- I think what you's saying is whatever
your morality is, I think that, you know,
folks are entitle that we
have freedom of religion,
we have freedom from religion.
Whatever your moral value is,
the issue is trying to
turn into legislation
and putting on someone else.
- We legislate what's right
and wrong all the time.
- Thinking even medically, you know,
like for indigenous women,
there are two times as likely to die
from pregnancy related complications.
Who's responsible for that murder
if she's forced to carry that baby?
- Well, I would be off working
on legislation altogether
where, you know, if the woman's
been taken advantage of,
or if they've instance situations
or if her life's at risk,
we can keep those options on the table.
- So all of a sudden, because
she could potentially die,
we'll make legislation to
where she can abort that baby.
And all of a sudden you're pro-abortion.
- No, I'm not pro-abortion
I personally would not like
her to choose that option.
I think science is, no, no, no, no.
I think science has come a long way
where that's actually not the case anymore
within our medical community.
And we need to continue
to increase funding
for those mechanisms to
provide more research
on how to keep the woman
alive in this situation.
- What is the end goal here
that abortion be illegal
and it be criminalized
and removed as a resource
forever from this country.
Is that the....
- Illegal and unthinkable.
- Illegal and unthinkable?
- Yeap.
- So it is culturally (indistinct)
- Culturally for women.
We want women to have
resources first of all,
to where they don't need an abortion.
And then abortion for the
abortionist is criminalized.
So an abortionist could go
to jail for performing it.
Women should not be criminalized
because at the end of the day,
women are victims of abortion as well.
- My name is Sebastian king,
and I am anti-abortion side.
My mom had an unplanned pregnancy
because she was taken advantage of
from the time she was 12 to 15.
And she was in and outta state custody.
And a judge even encouraged
her to have an abortion
and told my mom that she
won't amount to anything life
if she goes through with this pregnancy.
Because she chose life,
that's the only reason I'm here today.
And that's my mission is to ensure that
all life is protected.
- Abortion should be accessible
to rape and incest survivors.
- If you're pregnant from your brother
or your cousin or your father,
especially if it wasn't
consensual, or even if it was,
you should still have that
option to abort the baby.
And especially if you've been raped,
there are some people who have
that thought like, oh my God,
like, what if I, when I look at my child,
I relive that trauma.
- Just to remind you.
- And not saying that's how
all rape victims view it.
But it's just like some
women have that fear.
- Okay, so I was raped
for four years of my life violently.
More times than I can count.
And I did get pregnant when I was 15.
My rapist threatened me with
abortion multiple times.
Used it as a tool to keep me in his power.
He had the power to terminate evidence,
he had power against me.
I did end up losing her,
but I wanted her very badly.
I named her Rahi, which
is Rachel in English.
And I think it's very
important to humanize people
who are conceived and rape
because they're walking around right now.
- There's a lot of them.
And I think it's been very insulting
to place that on a human being.
I think that humans no
matter how they are conceived
are human beings and they
deserve to be respected
and their lives deserve to be respected.
- And I agree because that's me.
I agree a hundred percent.
And my mom has always told me
she doesn't view me as his.
Even on my birth certificate,
he's not my father, so.
- Oh, so I want tap on
what you said though.
Cause you said you really
wanted to keep your daughter.
And although you don't, you know,
see it as the right baby and stuff.
Other people who also go through
that traumatic experience
may actually see it like that, right?
You wanted that.
But there's other people
that had their choice
taken away from them.
They shouldn't be shamed
at going through this
and even having to live
through that experience
of the rape baby, you know what I mean?
- Here's the thing,
when you get an abortion
as a reaction to rape,
you are continuing the cycle of violence.
So you were raped,
that was a violent experience
that happened to you.
That wasn't your fault.
You're hurt, you've been victimized.
Why is it fair to further
victimize someone else
because you are hurt.
Why is it not..
- But you're seeing it
as a someone though, man.
I'm putting myself in a woman's shoes
or a human being's shoes, right?
You take my choice away.
You write me and for all, you know,
I might be a struggling human being,
making $8 an hour or something like that.
Crazy bills.
I might be living in my car.
I might be sleeping under the
dumpster behind McDonald's.
But now, because of your opinion
and my traumatic experience,
I get shamed because I
don't wanna bring this life
into the world, bro.
Oh, but you should give birth
and then put in foster care
if you don't want it, bruh.
- I Wanna touch on that too
just for a second.
Like for trauma.
I think absolutely what
I am passionate about
is giving people the choice.
And for you, you thought
a lot about your choice
and you wanted that pregnancy.
And I'm really sorry
that you lost that child.
And I also thought a lot about for myself
when I went through that experience,
what choice would be best for me?
And for me that was
not carrying the child.
And I think trauma is
such an interesting thing.
For me, not having control over a child,
growing inside of me and
changing my date of my life.
You know, that would be more traumatic
than the initial experience.
We don't know how people are gonna react,
but I do fight and would
want them to have the choice
to do what's best for them.
I think a strange
misconception that people have
about people who are pro-abortion
is that we don't have respect for life
or we don't care about children.
That's a absolutely not true.
I respect life very much.
Unfortunately, I've also seen
a lot of negative aspects
of our systems in the US,
like the Foster Care System.
It's out of that respect
that I believe people should have
the right to choose an abortion.
- America offers resources
to help you raise a child.
- There's tax benefits to having children.
I think there was also, you know,
in the latest round of COVID money,
there was funding for
women who've had children.
- Yeah, and there are so
many Christian charities
and so many different organizations
that want to help women,
you know, and the resources are there.
- Also government resources,
there are government resources
that help you take care of children.
Are there enough?
That is a different question.
- I was basically just
agreeing with what you said,
cause section eight, food
stamp, free healthcare,
school programs and whatnot.
Like there are resources,
are they enough, oh cool.
- That's how my mom
survived when she had me
because of government assistance.
So that's the only way she made it
because of that.
- I have been a pregnant teenager
and I've also been a teenage mother
on welfare and unemployed.
The number of resources that
are available state to state
is something that is atrocious.
But what it comes down to
is a lot of time and energy,
the choice between do I go to work
and get the money to pay rent
or do I go and I sit in the office
or do I go to this nonprofit
who's requiring me to
fill out this application
and come to a meeting in the daytime
when I'm supposed to be working.
- So you see it kind of like a job,
like you're clocking into filling paper
with you receiving your (indistinct).
- Low resources and creating
these sort of impossible
hurdles and more barriers for people
who are already experiencing
them to overcome,
to get the help is not a help at all.
- And I feel like a completely
like separate conversation
is it is extremely hard
to be a single mother
who is also a woman or person
of color and to get resources,
especially black woman.
They are notoriously even in that room
where they're giving birth,
they aren't taken seriously.
- Well, I just wanna say one thing
because I think it's important.
So I might not look it,
but I'm native American,
have my Cherokee card and everything.
We have universal healthcare
in the Indian community.
And when she went to have me as a child,
they told her in that
universal healthcare system
that she's not allowed
to have pain medicine
because that's a luxury.
So she got it through
government assistance.
So that's a big deal
that the United States
is more for than the
native American community.
- That is such a low bar.
- No, no, no, I'm not
saying that's acceptable,
but I'm saying like..
- It exists.
- It exists, that story exists.
- But there are literal reservations
out there that do not have water,
do not have electricity,
do not have internet that is in 2021.
Are those not resources to raise a child?
- So let's address that
instead of killing the baby.
- The question was does the
government provide resources?
No, does America provide resources?
No, that's unacceptable.
- Abortions will continue to
happen regardless of the law.
- Of course.
- All right, well.
- That ain't never going to change.
- I think of course
they'll continue to happen.
Law doesn't mean that
something is not gonna happen
at all anymore.
Just like rape, just like murder,
just like anything else we've outlawed.
Just because they're still going to happen
doesn't make it right.
- But if you criminalize doctors
and abortion providers, right?
That means we no longer have providers.
That means abortion is
no longer an option.
And that by default the
way that this country
and especially my state
legislates will mean,
and it has happened.
We have precedent, a woman
who tries to self induce
or who tries other non-medical methods
to have an abortion
can and has been criminalized.
What is the policy that
doesn't just absolutely
take away the right that people have
to access an abortion
regardless of what their beliefs are.
- If that child is a human being
deserving of the right to life,
then yes, it should be criminalized
just like murder of two year
olds and five year olds.
And adults is criminalized, right?
- But that's so different though.
You have people that's two
years old, already out the womb,
they been here for years, right?
And then you got these cells.
- Can I ask you something?
- Go ahead.
- When does it stop
being a clump of cells.
- Personally, I'm not worried
about the clump of cells.
- Decades of medical research
has not been able to land on that answer.
- And I'm trying to answer your question.
As far as cells...
- Do you believe that abortion
should be allowed on
nine months of pregnancy?
- I do feel that's a bit more extreme.
So I will agree on that as a..
- But let's not act like
women are just deciding
to get abortions at
like during their second
or third trimester.
And the woman who are doing it,
that's either that they're
going to die giving birth
or it's under some men to circumstances,
cause I doubt even myself,
I doubt that I would get to a six month,
seven month mark and then decide
I don't wanna make this commitment.
I feel like there's a
lot of this conversation.
Like when does it become wrong?
As if we're actually
going to get an abortion
at that time.
- A lot of the,
what pro-life people
would consider hostile
pro-choice comments and things like that
are a response to hostile pro-life people.
And I think that doesn't
get talked about in our side
because we don't like to fight each other.
But I think it's an important point
because I've seen absolutely
disgraceful comments
made towards women
who are going into clinics, you know,
who are obviously in a
very traumatizing situation
and you don't know what
that woman is going through.
And they're shouting obscenities at her.
And that's appalling.
And I think that we need
to take responsibility
as pro-life people to understand
they've experienced so much hurt
from our side of the community.
- And I agree with that.
I think, but from our
side of the aisle folks
who are very passionate
because they believe that's a life,
they believe that's a baby
and they wanna do everything
they can to save that child.
But I agree that our
rhetoric needs to be there
as a resource and another option.
And we can do that peacefully
and respectfully as well.
- I think on any side of
any controversial issue,
you're always gonna have those extremists,
same thing on the pro-abortion side,
people are always gonna have feelings
and people are always gonna
fight on that level, right?
But I think it's about coming up here
and saying like what
actually makes common sense
and how do we come up with policy
that doesn't force folks
to live by other people's values.
(enchanting music)